you
[Music]
I'm gonna get us started we may have a
few more people wandering in but I want
us to have as much chance as we can to
hear from cliff I'm really thrilled that
cliff gets to be here and I get to
introduce him to you if you have met him
already
cliff is a professor at the School of
Information at Michigan and he has been
a sort of a light in our field for
several years in both sir HCI but also
read much more widely in may the fields
that I play in I like to think that I've
been thinking about content moderation
for a long time but when I started
thinking about content moderation I
realized all the smart things cliff and
he said about Slashdot and online
communities that were sort of well ahead
of the things I was thinking about and
we're super helpful
so I'm really thrilled that you're here
thank you so much that's very kind
because I plan to steal about half your
book for my comments today so so my name
is cliff I am an old slash mater anybody
know slash that yeah all right there's
my old school nerds in the room bless
your hearts ha ha ha
and I was a researcher on slash dive
back and day I was actually their chief
scientist though I think that was mostly
jokingly said I study human-computer
interaction social computing computer
mediated communication
I'm also deep into organizing the sig
Chi conferences so if you don't know
anything about conference organizing let
me know and we can talk about that for
hours literally a couple of just
positions for myself just because of the
work that we're doing one thing this
presentation will have some work that
I'm doing in harassment and hate speech
and everything so there will be some
content that you might find distressing
or that's not very polite have that
being polite to the least of it
sometimes so just to give you a kind of
a heads-up on that I like to position
myself I am a moderate left in u.s.
political kind of spectrum which is like
I think conservative in Europe right and
a nice and I say that just because a lot
of the groups I study I try to always
challenge my own assumptions and beliefs
about especially the conservative groups
that I study and I always disclose with
them when I'm studying them who I am and
where I'm coming from and then I would
also say my brand of research is
interventionist if you're not familiar
with the HCI community which many of you
are not it's all oriented towards design
and coming up with solutions to problems
kind of thing which
has its strengths and limitations as a
scientific approach that I'd be happy to
talk about more to at some point the
other thing I want to mention is that
I'm drawing a lot of this work on a
shared NSF grant I have with Sarita yani
Rd Shana Beck and JJ Prescott
Cerreta was an intern here in 2011 she
met her husband grant here now they have
four beautiful like seriously adorable
children that I think you can all claim
credit for and she's a rock star
researcher I hate the term Rock sir
she's a great researcher JJ Prescott is
a colleague in the law school he has a
PhD in economics from MIT and a JD from
Harvard and he was a clerk for Merrick
garland so he's the guy who's there to
give me like a lot of impostor syndrome
about what it means to accomplish things
he's great and he's our informant about
justice and every couple weeks we sit
down with him and he teaches us about
the law and about criminal justice all
right so this idea that the idea that
I'm talking about here is that people do
bad things right this is not a new
concept this is something that our human
civilization has been dealing with and
in fact a lot of civilization is
structured around mitigating the bad
things that people do this is the Book
of the Dead which the from The Book of
the Dead is the papyrus of ani which it
lists a whole bunch of sins that you can
clean guilt over my favorite was I have
not multiplied my words and speaking
which just means that I'm not a bore I'm
not overly verbose which I love that the
idea of being a bore is a sin and is bad
news for academia defining bad has been
something you know philosophers
religious scholars everybody has really
thought about that for a long time I'm
not going to go into defining bad more
broadly but we think about them in terms
of norms and laws often right you can
break norms norms are basically what
should you do in polite society right
like there's no law that says that you
guys have to sit in chairs facing me
there's no law that says you can't be
talking right now over me right but we
have norms in a situation like this that
shape kind of our behavior and tell us
what to do
NORs are great because they're flexible
they adapt with social context there but
they're also imprecise and they're often
unfair norms are often embedded
dominant cultures and in a whole set of
things that make them so they're not
evenly applied to all people within a
system laws on the other hand are
inflexible they're clunky but they're
mostly precise and mostly fair not a
hundred percent obviously no he's gonna
look at the US criminal justice system
and say that's Rock and 100% fairness
but the goal is to be fair the goal is
equal application of the law to all
people no matter their status even if we
don't often achieve that goal so laws
and norms are ways that we have defined
what is good or bad and that's broadly
for all of human experience luckily I'm
not in charge of all of human experience
what I worry about is why do people do
bad things online and what can we do
about it
right and that's one of the things and I
always like to just position what does
online mean in this case so why do we
care about online I often accused the
HCI community of taking any aspect of
human endeavor and just adding the word
online to it and inventing a whole new
subfield right I've been guilty of that
myself maybe once or twice but let's
talk about what why does online matter
and a lot of that comes down to there's
lots of ways that computer mediated
communication people have talked about
why online matters the thing I think
about as affordances right affordances
are basically perceptual features in
both hardware and software that enable
people to perceive certain types of
actions that they can take right in both
hardware and software have affordances
Hardware part of the big push in social
media over the past 10 years have been
changes in hardware affordances longer
battery life for instance affords more
portability you know smaller size of a
device allows ubiquity those kinds of
things software also has a ton of
affordances your colleague Dana has
written about this a lot of courses that
have others of you maybe the idea here
isn't so much that we need to understand
the affordances per se for this talk but
I just my perspective is that software
systems and especially online social
media systems are designed environments
right they're architected they have
structure that somebody's making a
decision about so if they're architected
and they're designed we can design them
differently right and we think about a
lot of these platforms what they really
are they're just bundles of different
features
that are for different types of social
interactions that shape how people
behave makes sense
alright so people experience what I kind
of colloquially called in the title talk
adversarial interactions online that's a
really kind of antiseptic academic way
of saying people hurt each other and
there are very broad categories of these
bad behaviors I typically divide it into
people harming each other through social
media so this is like cyber bullying and
harassment daxing things like that
versus people we consider bad who use
social media in the same way like an
instant pop community would or a moms
group or anybody else right so social
media or online platforms in general
have a lot of great features that
support collective action those features
support your local environmental group
and they support your local white
supremacist group in pretty much the
exact same way so those are the two
broad categories people engaged in a
societally harmful action versus people
who are harming each other through these
platforms let me walk you through two
examples of types of adversarial
interactions that our groups are
studying at the University of Michigan
to kind of give you a sense of what
these things look like how many of you
study or take a look at kind of online
hate or any of these types of things a
couple we are it's just my usual
suspects oh great some of this will be
new for you and I apologize in advance
for ruining any hope for humanity that
you had when you walked into the room
all right so one thing I've been looking
at a lot right now is online
radicalization or red pilling they call
it they call it red pill and of course
because of the movie The Matrix you take
the blue pill the story ends you wake up
in your bed and believe whatever you
want to believe you take the red pill
you stay in Wonderland and I show you
how deep the rabbit-hole goes right
basically what it is is converting
somebody's point of view to a more
radical usually conservative facing
point of view right and they call it red
pill in because what they're trying to
do is to wake you up right they're
trying to teach you that the world's not
as simple or it's not the narrative that
you've been told even lied to your
entire life and if you wake up then
you'll see the truth
hate groups have grown in the United
States they've always been part of our
culture in the United States but they've
had a particularly good effect in the
past few years and they've early
adopters and effective users of online
technologies this is the Southern
Poverty Law Center attracts different
types of hate groups in the United
States and defines what a hate group is
which can often be kind of contentious
and have tracked a little over a
thousand hate groups operating as kind
of structured organizations within the
United States all of those online hate
groups use social media online platforms
collaborative tools to structure their
work activity right the work of hate is
something they do and of course they
wouldn't see themselves as hate groups
and that's part of where I want us to
make sure that we think about
challenging our own beliefs it's not
like somebody goes into the internet
europa group and thinks oh I'm gonna
really hate on people they think that
they're loving their own or they think
that they're trying to create a better
society because massagin a ssin of the
races is destroying both races and they
just want to keep people separate in
etcetera etcetera etcetera rights they
they usually they wouldn't describe
themselves as bad people most of these
folks right they have a point of view
that we consider socially deviant in a
mainstream cultural standpoint but to
themselves within their subgroup they
have a consistent set of beliefs and see
themselves as good actors and what they
tend to do is try to use online
platforms to spread their message in one
way or the other and part of how they do
that is by creating strong in groups or
out groups one of the ways I first
started studying all here's an example
the red pill and reddit this is a the
red pill is a specific community or a
specific subreddit related to the in
cells community in cell stands for
involuntary celibates it's a group of
men who believe that especially feminism
has destroyed the u.s. society has
created a set of weak men that if we
redistribute power to a more patriarchal
society that will have a stronger better
Society right and so they believe for
instance in forced sexual relationships
and a whole bunch of
kind of really what I think of as gross
ideas what struck me when I first
started studying these groups is how
similar radicalization is no matter what
the ideology of the radical right so
this is a group that was created out of
Europe and out of The Hague basically
looking at how does Islamic radical
belief systems start and then propagate
amongst each other and you can see some
of the same processes as we talked about
right you create an in-group and you
create an out group with the in-group
you set narrative messages about how the
in-group is right how they're trying to
do the right thing and how they're good
people when you define the out group you
imbue them with negative values you show
them that they're responsible for your
suffering in one way or the other so for
Isis and other kinds of Islamic radicals
the in-group was the caliphate and the
goal is the caliphate and that true
believers of their ideology were just
trying to create a paradise on earth for
people who have been suppressed by an
out-group which is mostly Westerners
with good evidence that westerns
Westerners had caused severe damage to
parts in the Middle East right and so
you create that out group you show
they're responsible for your suffering
you enhance the values of your in-group
and that's how you start to radicalize
people now the best way to do this is
just throwing messages out there and
trying to get people to watch your
messages that process overall is the
same process that we see it whether it's
about misogyny about white supremacy
about hatred of Jewish people whatever
it happens to be any radical process
seems to follow this same basic pattern
keeping in make an in-group make an out
group and then exacerbate them the other
thing we see here is that there's a
spectrum of effects that we see I think
a lot of people trivialize the effects
of radicalization like well how
successful they're gonna be they're not
the in sales movement is not going to
take every male in the United States and
convert them into thinking about for
sexual relationships right but that's
not what they're trying to do and when
radicals think about people who are not
them they have this whole spectrum of
people from people who are vehemently
against them who
are useful in that they can be mocked
and kind of characterized as the
out-group to people who are engaged who
are reading their comments or at least
kind of the more vanilla forms of their
comments to kind of these supporters the
radicals themselves call these normies
right there are people who are
sympathetic to your ideas they may not
engage in violent actions themselves
they may not ever you know do what a lot
of in sales members do which is engage
in mass shooting or something like that
but they will denigrate women in an
online forum or they'll do something
else that supports kind of the overall
cause that these people have the other
thing that we find this is a really
great article out of nature that just
came out this year these hate groups and
these radicalization groups are
incredibly resilient and spread across
networks very richly so we see it across
the top are basically these are all the
green nodes are sub threads within a
Russian discussion site that's famous
for kind of hosting conspiracy theories
and all right content and you can see
the the February 13th 2018 is before the
parkland shooting and you can see the
kind of disparity of that network the
edges I think that they said in the the
next are people who are kind of posting
in two of these communities within this
kind of a conspiracy community overall
and so you can just see that these
communities change and grow richer over
time the basic lesson is that and this
one is where the they had started to
shut down the red notes here are shut
down conspiracy theory sites that were
being tracked but we see that more and
more people were going into the
conspiracy sites and discussing one
another kind of the you know and it was
all about false flag that parkland was a
false flag operation that this mass
shooting had it happened that it was all
just crisis actors who were making up to
having been shot which is a common
thread when he that you see with mass
shootings more broadly so it's a really
resilient pattern and one of the things
that make it particularly hard to fight
is it can move across platforms
platforms can try to solve their own
problems but they rarely saw of each
other's proud
and so when you move across platforms
and can move from node to node within
this kind of conspiracy or
radicalization Network then it makes it
really hard to tamp down radicalization
the pathway for this is also shows a
really kind of rich ecology this is a
very simplified model that it kind of
came up with that's in no way completely
accurate but it just gives you an idea
where you have a site like telegram
which is encrypted discussion platform
I've been studying the proud boys which
is a white supremacist group for a
couple of years and they use telegram
for instance like you would contact
somebody through a Google Mail address
they would send you credentials to get
into proud boys once you kind of prove
your bona fides and telegram is where
they coordinate a lot of their action
right because the encryption protects
them from law enforcement to a large
extent but each han would then often be
a site where you would move to
coordinate more publicly so you might
take your private coordination or your
private plan from telegram move it to a
Chan which got closed but kind of back
again or 4chan or one of these other
sites that exists then the process is to
move it to extreme but not that extreme
kind of other platform so you can move
it to Reddit for instance to the red
pill or to the Donald or something like
that take the content that you
strategize here move it into a more
mainstream site where you get more
eyeballs attached to it that intersects
with kind of the jordan peterson ben
shapiro podcast world where they will
pick up these fringe ideas from these
more extreme sites and talk about them
sometimes support them sometimes not but
they have a conservative audience so
there the connection then becomes to a
podcast like Joe Rogan's podcast anybody
listen to Joe Rogan watch his show yeah
me too he is one of the most popular
podcasters in the United States right
now right huge huge audience and he'll
have on people like ben shapiro or milo
innopolis or you know the Infowars got
Alex Jones and he legitimizes basically
this fringe discussion that's been
happening to a mainstream discussion and
then that gets pushed into Facebook
memes that your aunt shares you know
back and forth or your uncle or whoever
it is we
at least one family member right who
keeps sharing these memes some of those
are created authentically in these
spaces some of them are explicit
disinformation campaigns yeah I don't
think anybody's done the systematic work
which is something we should do the from
the motivations I've seen expressed in a
lot of these communities some it's just
genuine belief right some people feel
like this are actual conspiracies that
are happening for some people though it
is the idea that stricter gun regulation
is worse than the occasional shooting
so whatever derails the message that
would lead to more gun regulation is
worth the railing by any means necessary
and then you know the Joe Rogan's first
Rogen's a good example he's just he's a
libertarian who believe he's an
absolutist view point towards free
speech and so he just feels like he's a
good actor trying to give everybody a
voice in the discussion all right
so an example work we're doing in this
space we're looking we're doing work
that is a combination of kind of data
scraping from twitch and YouTube gamer
channels and we have any small kids in
the room you know how much they watch
video game streaming now it's one of the
fastest growing areas of kids
entertainment to watch other people play
video games well the alt-right knows
this and so some of these radicalized
groups what they've decided to do and we
picked up some of this chatter in
telegram and recently on me we is to do
what I call pink pilling which is you're
not going to convert a kid into a mass
shooter not necessarily but what you do
is you pepper your game stream with
language that's purposely dismissive of
progressive terms right so you use terms
like safe space or snowflake as a way to
denigrate progressive values without the
kids even knowing they're being
radicalized to denigrate progressive
terms right and that's a
Pacific radicalization strategy that was
we're right now trying to figure out how
to best test this with kids and how to
measure what the effect of this is I
don't think either the people the
radicals or we know if this is an
effective strategy or not if this
actually does change anything but they
often they're very experimental and
they'll try lots of different methods
like this all right so that's
radicalization another big area of work
that we look at and think about is
online harassment so these are just the
standard Pugh slides you have to show
every time you talk about online
harassment lots of people experience
online harassment in the country mostly
that's offensive name Coleen purposeful
embarrassment gets more serious stalking
sexual harassment daxing revenge porn we
just saw of course a US Congresswoman
have to step down because of a revenge
porn incident that was aimed against her
you know lots and lots of people
experiencing this and it's
disproportionately being experienced by
the vulnerable people both young people
of color women of color there are
especially vulnerable to these types of
effects most more than a quarter of
Americans have decided not to post
because they see others being harassed
so it has a chilling effect on what we
think of as the positive benefits of
these social computing platforms and you
can see the harms that people talk about
which is largely stress and emotional
problems but we do see of course
suicides and problems losing jobs etc
etc that can happen through these things
as well so online harassment is bad
harassment in general is bad online
harassment particularly hard to stop
though one example that we've been
working on recently a sea lion teen on
Wikipedia my student Elizabeth Whitaker
did an internship with Erin half-acre at
I think of a picture of them yeah so
first of all who knows the term see
lining a couple of you right it's
basically a lightweight form of
harassment ofits lately it's a form of
harassment where you try to derail a
conversation by politely insisting on
evidence or a certain tone that you have
no intention of actually respecting
right and it's based off this old comic
is the origin of the term see lining if
you ever wondered you're all reading
this I'll wait two more seconds while we
it's a really common strategy that you
see in a lot of political discussion
boards and so one of the things we were
looking at we were just talking I was
talking to Sean about what's the
definition of civility and how a lot of
people call for civility these days I
like ZZ pop which Reese's definition she
wrote paper in 2014 where she defined it
not so much as we'd be nice to each
other which i think is kind of the
common and unhelpful definition of
civility but that were collaboratively
working towards an end goal together and
so we decided to study Wikipedia TOC
pages we did this with Aaron half-acre
who's a principal scientist at the
Wikimedia Foundation Elizabeth's a PhD
student in my lab and what we did is we
found that we interviewed women editors
and we talked about what kinds of
experiences were they having we weren't
actually looking for harassment at that
time we were just really interested
Wikipedia has long had a gender problem
and she was just interviewing women
editors and she found a lot of
harassment but it wasn't obvious
harassment one type of harassment that
they were having were things like this
right they were being accused by male
editors of not abiding to the n POV
standards the neutral point of view
standards and being asked to prove that
they that they were being neutral which
is a you know really hard thing so that
what we were finding were that people
were using the policies and rules of
Wikipedia to actually harass and to keep
down women editors on the site and to
chase them out of the space right so it
felt like from a long distance view it
looked like a very reasonable thing well
I'm just asking you to follow the rules
I'm just asking for evidence that you're
following our policies but of course its
effects were a harassing effect right
for the women who are involved all right
so those are a couple of times we have a
lot of studies going on in these
different spaces this gets us into these
bad things happen but what do we do when
bad things happen offenses if we think
about the criminal justice system more
broadly need to be both detected or
caught you know and they need to be
punished in online space that's no
different machine learning tools have
gained a lot of popularity and have
gotten better over time in detecting
some of these big things bad things that
happen from the early days of just kind
of bag of word approaches to looking for
bad words and spaces to now much more
sophisticated ways of detecting bad
behavior machine learning tools have
gotten pretty good and the platforms are
really depending heavily on these
machine learning learning platforms into
the future right zuckerberg himself has
made a lot of public statements about
how he expects in five years to stop the
misinformation and harassment problems
on facebook through the use of machine
learning tools he's he's been wrong
before is all I'll say about that's all
I'll say about that and even though and
even then the problem he comes is once
you detect a crime which i think is
analogous to like arresting a criminal
you still then need to punish them you
need to remediate the crime somehow and
how do we as a species think about
remediating offenses or bad things that
happen what is the goal of justice is
basically what this is right how do we
think about how justice should work this
is something that is of course a long
another here's another old
archaeological slide the code of the
Hammurabi is well known to many of us of
course it comes and from it comes the
term if a man destroyed the eye of
another man they shall destroy his eye
right so I for an eye justice is
literally out of the Hammurabi code what
I what I always forget and I always find
somewhat depressing is then it got talks
about freemen which is a type of serf
and then slaves and like how there are
lesser punishments for all of these
subordinate or lower status people that
I find a little bit depressing but you
know the the basics is still this
retributive approach to justice right so
the Code of Hammurabi became a template
of sorts and it wasn't the first code
the Code of Hammurabi was actually you
know probably a consolidation of a lot
of codes that had happened before it and
we actually have multiple versions of
the code that we know we know it changed
and evolved over time during this period
in the Fertile Crescent but in the
Fertile in egypt and mesopotamia this
code of law and this idea of retributive
justice became the dominant form of
justice now that wasn't true universally
right across the world there were other
forms of justice in Africa in the Amer
in Asia being developed that were
somewhere retributive but others were
not and we'll talk more about that in a
second
that spread then to eat to the grease
from especially from Egypt and Aristotle
and Socrates became the basis for a lot
of how Western thought in general dealt
with the idea of justice and we don't
really challenge that right does anybody
ever think that a crime shouldn't be
punished right that we have a model for
a tribute of justice that especially if
you're a westerner is just baked super
deep into our heads and in fact one of
the things I always find challenging
when I give this talk or I talk about
this work is people can't envision
another way of doing justice right often
I'm a I will ask people well why do we
need police right and just as a kind of
provocation aquestion and people gasp
visibly about that like it's just it's
so baked into who we are as a culture so
retributive justice as it's been handed
down to us from that long history is
primarily concerned with delivering a
just dessert for a morally wrong act I
was exactly 42 years old when I found
out that's the right spelling of just
dessert too I thought it meant like a
bad pudding that you got because you've
been a bad boy
and I spelled it wrong for 42 actual
years but reparative justice is that you
deserve what you get right that if you
do something bad if you break the code
of society that something bad will
happen to you and that is of course how
we treat our current criminal justice
system we often find that this
epistemology is so deep in our heads
that we have a strong retributive
mindset as people and in fact when we
feel like the law is not being
appropriately retributive we will often
be retributive ourselves there's a form
of harassment that takes place in online
spaces called the pile on which is
basically somebody does a bad thing and
a whole bunch of people pile on to tell
that person what a bad thing they did
and harass them so it's a form of
harassment but it feels just it's mob
justice basically right kind of one of
our famous examples of this is justine
sacco who got onto a plane on a plane
in England said something racist and by
the time she landed in South Africa her
life had been completely destroyed right
that felt like justice to a lot of
people she had said something she
shouldn't have said and so her life was
disrupted because of that it's a fence
and a retributive act right we did a
series of studies with my student
Sarita's and my student Lindsey
Blackwell and a person at the time
chungyang who was a master student at
the time but now as a PhD student at
Carnegie Mellon where we were trying to
test this right how how what is people's
propensity towards justice and
especially retribution in online spaces
Lindsey has since gone on and broken my
heart and gone to work for Facebook so
she's doing this work over there so we
basically prompted people they were
placed into experimental conditions
where we were told that one of the
people in this thread Sarah had stolen a
hundred dollars from an elderly couple
another group in another condition were
told she had sold a thousand dollars
from an elderly couple and then we had
Sarah say this rude terrible thing I
hate that word and it's interesting the
pre-testing we did to figure out that
that was the right word to use I can
have a whole separate conversation about
the pre-testing for that people when
there was more money involved when it
was seem like a me or Sarah's original
crime was higher felt that she deserved
that more than for the lower crime right
we have this retributive framework kind
of baked into how we think about where
you respond to people we also did a
followup with this where we looked at
interventions and we found that if there
were comments on this agreeing with
Sarah
then people felt even better about the
retributive justice that Sarah was
receiving so it's just you know we find
that people have a strong appetite for
this the other thing we did is took
measurements that our survey
measurements cycle of Social Survey
measurements of people's kind of
propensity towards retribution and we
found that in fact there was great
variance in our population of people who
had different Penn cities towards
retribution and as you might expect that
propensity affected how much they
thought this was a justice
tweet at the original person we're
following up with that work one of the
things we're trying to do now is very
for instance interface features so if
you see a reported sign does that change
whether you think this is appropriate or
if you think this is just we're also
adding likes and dislikes and you know
kind of subtle interface changes but the
thing is we don't know the scientific
impacts of some of these subtle changes
remember I talked about affordances and
design we don't know how these designs
affect people's belief about what should
or shouldn't happen so we just we need
to start doing that grunt work of just
systematically testing all these
different things and seeing what happens
yeah yeah so that's probably after this
one
we have strong theories for why we would
expect this to be different if it were
male and female or if it were non-binary
or if there were racial differences we
we kept everybody white women
specifically to try to hold constant the
race and gender effects that we
anticipate you said for the motivation
for sort of testing all these different
features that is to figure out what the
optimal design is but I feel like the
policy is just to delete this tweet
right could be yeah I mean that's the
other thing we don't know that for this
language like these free button what you
just deleted right well I wish that were
more clear a lot of we'll talk more
about why just deleting it probably
wouldn't work as a feature because a lot
of platforms are just allergic to
deletion as a moderation scheme yeah so
the problem you have is that retributive
mechanisms often fail online there's a
great lead-in to all right now this is
my advisor and office mate Paul Resnick
wrote a paper about this with Eric
Friedman 110 years ago now called the
social cost of cheap pseudonyms where
they did this with eBay data and it's
just it's the sock puppet problem right
if you get punished for an action you
take in an online space you just create
a new account and carry on with your
dirty business right like that's a cheap
pseudonym or the ability to create
multiple accounts really easily which
all these platforms are incentivized to
do make it so
it's really hard to enforce people
imagine for instance if our only
punishment if you're in an offline
justice system where that we could we
would kill you right like which is the
same as kind of like deleting a person
or canceling them from the platform but
it's okay because you can immediately
create a new body and just carry on with
your business
right like the allegory is between kind
of our offline criminal justice system
and online punishment really break down
what do you think about the affordances
of the software and how we can't really
enforce much of how we do in an offline
space there's no allegory to jail really
in the internet so I often turn back to
good old Larry Lessig when I'm feeling
lost about what to do about this
I know it's ridiculous for a grown
person to depend on this framework for
theory but I do and I like it because he
talks about the law legal policies and
site policies for instance can the law
help solve this problem right can we
somehow in the u.s. make it so that's
illegal to use that word or to do things
the thing I have learned teaching at the
law school for the past two years at
Michigan is no the US law is not going
to be of any help to us don't look to it
turn away from the law is not there for
you the other thing that we have our
site policies right you can create a
site policy saying certain things are
not allowed on our site and of course
we've seen over the past few weeks huge
debates and arguments about that play
out in the media right so Mark
Zuckerberg has agreed to allow lies and
false dis misinformation and
disinformation in political ads on
Facebook right and that's a policy
decision that Facebook is main that
there's been plenty of critique about
and discussion back and forth about
whether that's the right thing to do so
we also have the architecture which is
kind of the code of these site can we
change could we make new interfaces can
we change basically the nudge philosophy
right if I if I put in the right thing
in this optimal design am I going to
enable people to have the right
mechanism or the right kind of reaction
one of the things we found in another
study that we did with the site heart
mob is people are really unclear if
they've been harassed or not so we did
interviews with people would face
harassment in heart mob and the thing
that stuck out to
was the the reason why they went to
heart mob in the first place was it
wasn't clear to them how hurt they
should be right they had felt attacked
they had felt piled on and in one case
one was doxed and was but because they
don't that there's no common experience
there's no framework for this part of
what they were looking for is just
validation that what they experienced
was harassment right so how can we help
shape some of these processes all right
so other reasons why this won't work as
tom has written about section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act of 1996 means
that the platforms are really just
indemnified from any actual
responsibility from all of this and
that's just not going to change there's
been whispers of that changing but
that's just not gonna change there's
actually a section 230 if you've never
had a chance to read it I don't
anticipate that you do I just yeah
attempts at moderation inevitably lead
to false positives right the famous
example diamond and silk for instance
conservative video bloggers got banned
from Facebook and the first weather the
last time Zuckerberg was at Congress
that's all any conservative congressman
would ask him about is why did you ban
diamond and silk they're great in the
whole nine yards and those false
positives provide ammunition that the
companies don't want so recently there
was a White House social media summit
which was basically just a bunch of
people complaining about how Google and
Twitter and Facebook are banning
conservative voices and things like that
one of my favorites for that devyn
newness has been an incredibly activist
in terms of trying to change this and
that's because people made parody
accounts called Devon Nunez as Cao and
Devon Newton as his mother and Devon
Nunez this cow was relentless at
trolling and teasing Devon newness and
he got super mad about that like way
more mad than you would think a grown
man would get about a cow but he got mad
platforms in general do not want to be
the arbiters of free speech again as
Tarleton has written about writte
for a variety of good reasons one is
they're always gonna make a mistake for
somebody right no matter what decision
they make somebody's gonna be mad at
them for their decision and these are
companies that do not want people to be
mad at them because mad people don't
watch ads
you know and so so they have to be
carefully they want somebody else to
make this decision Zuckerberg has been
calling for Congress to act on this for
years at this point wanting something
more like GDP our in Europe to handle
some of these issues recently the Senate
had hearings about cross-platform
initiatives that they could get in place
but if the platforms are in charge of
this they make mistakes and each one of
those mistakes gets hit by the
mainstream media I just said mainstream
media and they get a lot of crap scale
is a huge problem as you guys know from
yours position how do I actually scale
up any of these solutions to the scale
of how much how many seconds of YouTube
video are there uploaded every single
moment of the day right platforms are
federated I can come up with a solution
that will fix the incredible
radicalization and child pornography
problems we see on YouTube but that
won't then switch to me we and it won't
switch to twitch all these platforms
have to come up with independent
solutions they do talk to one another
but still really hard to have one common
framework across all of them so for that
and a couple of other reasons we typical
retributive approaches are not working
to solve the problem of moderation we
are recommending restorative justice as
at least a way of looking at how we
remediate these bad things that happen
in a different way so restorative
justice was started to become really
popular in the 1970s a lot of it stems
from feminist critique of like John
Rawls and and typical William Conte and
typical ideas about justice it was
informed by African American Studies and
Native American Studies and a whole
bunch of kind of if you were against the
colonialists you were helping to inform
basically this restorative justice
approach and the idea of her sort of
justice I think is most commonly known
by people through the Truth and
Reconciliation Committee Commission post
apartheid right which was you know if
you compare that with the Nuremberg
trials and different that's the the
ultimate retributive approach to justice
and truth and reconciliation was the
ultimate restorative approach painful
for everybody did not go perfectly in
any way shape or form but it was
probably the most large-scale
restorative justice approach we'd seen
at the time so goals of restorative
justice are to put key decisions into
the hands of the
most affected by the crime its to not
just file a report and have that go off
into the ether and then receive an
antiseptic decision back from the
platform it's to make justice more
healing and more transformative not to
punish but to heal and now does that
change your mindset and to reduce the
likelihood of future offences which is a
huge part of this guiding questions of
restore of dress and this is all taken
from Howard's there who's a an old
school like he was there in the 70s with
the beaded jacket and the and the roach
clip and all that stuff really really
selling was sort of justice in the
criminal justice system and he's written
up these things I'm stealing this off
from him so who has been harmed that's
an important question what are their
needs whose obligations are these who
has a stake in the situation what are
the causes and what is the appropriate
process to put things right right like
if you think about this as the center of
how you remediate an online harassment
or the process of radicalization or any
of those things at the very least I
think it opens up a creative new toolset
to start to deal with some of these bad
things that can happen in an online
space I don't know that solves the whole
problem and we'll get into that in a
second and I don't need you to read
these and OHSAS just put this up in case
you had access to the slides but there's
a whole bunch of sign post right one of
my favorite ones is find a meaningful
way to involve community members and to
respond to the community basis of the
crime right restorative justice
approaches bring in the community and
they think about what's the harm to the
community not just to the victim and not
just to the perpetrator all right so
there's a lot of critiques of
restorative justice and there always
have been one is that a place it has a
potential at least a place to much
burden on the victim right one of the
things that can be reach Ramat izing is
to have to face your accuser and if that
doesn't if that is not structured
particularly well then you're gonna have
a hard time recently president Trump
invited some parents of a child who had
been killed in the UK by an ambassador
to the White House and had tried to set
up a restorative justice meeting right
between the ambassador's wife who had
killed their son and the parents of the
son but that was clumsily handled you
can't just put people into a room
together and expect restorative
processes to happen it has to be
mediation that's restructure and that
that's often where victims get harmed
is when there's not those processes in
place it may not fit every crime there
are most likely crimes that are not
remediable right that cannot be restored
and that should be sanctioned in
different ways than restorative justice
outcomes are not operationalize well if
I send a guy to the electric chair
that's a result right if I if I get a if
I give you a ticket for $75 for parking
in a handicapped spot that's a that's an
operationalize measurable result if I
restore your appreciation of the
handicapped and make it so that you
would reconsider parking in those spots
again much harder to operationalize and
think of as a success and then doesn't
scale right which is always a complaint
with these things well actually I mean
I'm gonna make the argument that it can
scale better so where have we seen this
before can we use regional restorative
justice principles to address any of
these online adversarial interactions so
we see this in a couple of places of the
League of Legends tribunal system
anybody ever play League of Legends it's
an online game and they had this great
process by where if you committed a
transgression you could be reported and
you and the person who was accusing you
of the crime had to go in front of a
tribunal which was a jury of other
players at your same level who would
then hear the evidence on both sides and
help mediate a connection between you
right it's one of the largest scale
restorative systems I've ever seen in an
online community and it worked at the
scale of tens of thousands right because
of course you can systematize that you
can just put in place a system that will
go out and find a random set of players
at an appropriate level you can
systematize the data collection and what
you need and the whole nine yards I
think you actually can do restorative as
scale in online environments much better
actually than you can in an offline
environments where logistics and
transaction costs usually sink the value
of restorative projects yeah
we described earlier the you know
private forums or telegram wherever
folks coordinate and then come and say
yeah I don't think that's a great
question so breguet Dean basically which
is where you bring in a group of people
to support a point of view a system like
this could be vulnerable to this so this
one's not because the players are chosen
randomly from a very large pool so the
opportunity to set up a brigade from
such a large pools would be very hard
but the this particular tribunal system
might not stop radicalization you might
need to think of other mechanisms my the
student Lindsey Blackwell did a recent
radio thing with NPR's on the media
where she and the NPR producer tried to
conduct a restorative justice approach
to people who had been banned from
different sub reddits for different
transactions against moderators right so
in three cases what they did is brought
the moderator who had banned the user
and the user together to try to mediate
and solve the problems it's not
scientific approach this is an NPR
approach right and in one of the cases
it worked beautifully
in one of the cases it kind of worked in
one case it failed but you know as I
pointed out to Lindsay that neither of
them had any training or skill in
mediation I'm not sure that the
mediation was actually any good which is
a huge x-factor but really interesting
podcast if you're interested in hearing
a larger discussion of this of
restorative justice and how it might
work so next steps Sarita and I are
working on a representative survey to
measure kind of this perception of
justice more broadly across a wider
group of people we're running different
experiments to test different mechanisms
in a lab environment and then we're
gonna run field testing of the
environments we're working on corporate
partners to do that with as saying ahead
next door lined up but they fell through
recently Quorra might participate so
looking at different places that allow
us to test this and kind of live
actually environment so that's a couple
years down the road I'm gonna skip these
so we can talk
the main question that I have is what do
you think can we use these restorative
approaches to design these features what
should we be thinking about when we do
this what I'll leave the rest of the
time for Q&A so what should I be
thinking about that I'm not and that's
what I happy
so imagine in the salt a sort of
hypothetical problem of how do we create
a validated user so we certify them
based on you know maybe in Equifax
background check over there where they
answer a couple questions and assume we
can solve the oh you've been in problem
right yeah piece of salt cheap student
problem but also protect users and in me
somehow so that maybe you don't expose
their identity but you can at least say
only a registered user can engage with
the platform how would these challenges
change and would solve someone would it
make them more challenging in other ways
I think it depends a lot of the platform
anonymity always gets blamed for a lot
of the worst things that happen in these
spaces but we've done a series of
studies that show that even when actors
are not anonymous at all like when
they're using their real names they
still behave pretty much almost as bad
as they do when they're fully anonymous
right and so I think that'll solve a
portion of the problems and a certain
type of problem but if you scale up to
more diverse groups or you're as good as
anonymous because there's never any
potential for consequence then the real
ID thing kind of falls apart a little
bit
I guess so much of this has in the
background just like what norms exist on
these different platforms we kind of
taught norms have changed over time and
over yeah think of the relationship
between norms and that's a good one so
the problem with features is often they
afford things that the designers did not
intend right and so you can take a lot
of features and pervert them into
harassment features trying to think of a
good example right now but it's easy to
for instance do this in games and a lot
of online communities so with norms
norms can be at the macro scale for an
entire site or they can be micro for a
particular group within a community and
this gets into the theory of social
deviance right when we think about
social deviants like the classic example
in the sociological literature is gang
members right a gang is socially deviant
at the large scale their norms are very
different from the kind of mass norms of
the society but within their cluster
they have tight norms for themselves and
so norms interact weirdly to answer your
question with features because micro
norms exist within subcultures and it's
hard to know what those are and to
predict how they're going to interact
with features why do we need a special
system online is it because you know
it's more frequent because you know you
I think you start with the assumption
that this is a particular problem online
but I mean the thing is I'm I haven't
actually seen any data to really show
that you know there are so many
interactions you know I you know you
look at pictures online you look at
photos look at all kinds of things yeah
I mean how much worse is this problem
online really you know compared to all
the terrible things that happen in
offline meetings and so on so that
we need a completely different sort of
justice system if this would be like
sort of epidemics comes like hundred
times as frequently as happens offline I
cry see this but like you know I've seen
the standard sort of really justified
and in fact a flying harms are actually
our users are often much worse right
like you're talking a lot of physical
harm you're talking domestic assault
like offline harms can actually be even
more consequential than these often are
much more consequential than these
online arms I and I don't think we need
a different approach this sort of
approach has been applied to the offline
environment right and usually the
effects are strong reduced recidivism
people feel like they most often feel
like they've gotten some out of the
process both the victim and the
perpetrator often leads to positive
community effects as they've been
measured over the past 30 or 40 years
the problem has always been the money
the scale and the fact that we have such
a strong retributive perspective that
people feel like it's not enough justice
being done so my my argument is that
there's nothing different about the
online environment that makes for sort
of justice more appealing it's actually
the online environment makes retributive
justice not effective and we should try
this other branch of justice of having
real consequences if your cost end up
being good actors imagination of
consequences is the idea that
restorative would not never attributed
its taking for me the time for training
course and then the embarrassment I
either retributive or assorted or is the
argument to do retribution that also
restores alright yeah I know I don't
exactly know the answer to your question
in an online context offline restorative
is most often paired up with retributive
like a good example of sobriety courts
so if you get caught drunk driving you
can go to jail or you can go to sobriety
court which is a much more restorative
approach where you meet with victims of
drunk drivers etc etc etc and it's a
process that's instead of you being
incarcerated but the threat of
incarceration still holds over your head
right like you keep going to sobriety
court because it's much better than
peeing in front of a bunch of people in
jail right so it's it's that in the u.s.
at least how we've done restorative
justice has very much been embedded in
the threat of retributive justice now
there are other places I need to
investigate more like New Zealand has
been using restorative justice for their
juvenile offenders for the past 15 years
and have great success in preventing
further recidivism into crime and every
Duke they claim reduce their crime rates
because of using restorative approaches
at the right time I don't know for sure
yeah which usually I would imagine
involves Penniman person
how does that work with our language
it's always struck me that the reason
people are more noxious online is
they're not actually in acting
yeah the center of common theories about
why people interact poorly online is
rich yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't you
want to have a face-to-face interaction
but you would have a richer than usual
interaction that's guided by a mediator
of some type right yeah it would it it
wouldn't necessarily have to be
face-to-face or visual or you want to
have to out yourself or who you actually
are but it would be maybe more
synchronous or there there would be some
richer media approach to having the
interaction
you you had that differentiation at the
beginning between people who do bad
things online and bad groups who used
online and I guess I'm wondering how do
you see
in both of these cases make it easier
that is a rich question just as Randy
just two quick things I know people want
to get home to their families and so so
a couple of things one is this is a
broad weakness of the criminal justice
system right criminal justice tended to
come out of both moral philosophy and
individual psychology so criminal
justice as a set of theories doesn't
have a great approach to societal
infrastructure problems their approaches
the individual has transgressed we must
deal with the individual right now what
we're starting to look at now is social
work theories my wife's a social worker
and when she hears about this work she's
like you're an idiot
so she says that a lot I'm not sure why
and I do think there are there are
social work theories and sociological
theories that we should bring into this
to tie with criminal justice to enrich
that perspective
thank you one of my observations in
terms of seeing irassman in offensive
language and stuff like that
how's me I mean I sort of funny way back
in the nineties when you know before
there's a browser speaking of
sophisticated today in one of the places
that it was very clear what you're
talking about is the society culture
country and AOV or Syria and in some of
them each one of those cultures right
the investment came in a different
manner yeah and for instance Latin
American countries it's 100 percent of
the time people would get frustrated
because they could didn't have a good
argument or politically different or
whatever any another positive time went
in a sexual connotation yeah and to the
point that a lot of people say I'm you
know that's not the place for me yeah
III don't see it changing very much I
mean it might have changed the issues
but it really shows an enormous
frustration is the person who starts
whereas because he doesn't have a in
answer to whatever is being said or or
done in I think the first step in this
according for answers to themselves I
think it whatever is there that
irritates them or push their buttons is
something invalidates them profoundly if
so therefore it goes into this sort of
avalanche of whatever is at hand you
know could be the bullying or or you
know whatever the language they use it
to to vent their activity so what you
say about restorative it would be great
but
you know what can be done I mean I in
fact I think having a place to values I
go to that because there you are not
physically attacking someone or doing
something else yeah there's a bunch of
common theories about that - yeah I what
a couple that's rich statement so I'm
only the only thing I'm gonna pick up on
there is I think there's there are a
bunch of cultural differences and how
people express these things that I'm not
qualified to answer and I hope people
pick up the work
Katie Pierce at the University of
Washington for instance is doing a bunch
of really great work looking at some of
cultural differences and how people
respond to these kind of social media
aggressions and more much more work
needs to be done in the areas are
talking about
thank you thanks for having me